so the question here is why is the
government
after promising not to do this
repeatedly still hiding information on
something that is very much in the
public interest which is what are these
things these ufos we know they're real
we don't know what they are probably
have a right to know that it's our
government after all but they're still
hiding it from us why
luella zondo is one of the world's
exodus maybe the world's expert on this
he used to study ufos for the pentagon
he joins us tonight lou thanks so much
for coming on so let's just go right to
motive
we know these are real we know the
pentagon takes them seriously if not in
public why in the world will they still
be hiding this information from us
yeah i mean it is kind of peculiar isn't
it tucker that you know really the day
before thanksgiving the pentagon decides
to announce the creation of this office
when they've had you know four years to
do it beforehand um i do think it is a
good idea to have a centralized office
not so sure that it's good to put it
where they want to put it at the end of
the day the organization they want to
put it under is my old office it's the
under secretary of defense for
intelligence which is an oversight
capability not an operational capability
and plus there are still some of the old
elements in that organization that
really didn't do us much favors when i
was running the program four years ago
right well that's obvious in fact if it
weren't for you effectively blowing the
whistle we wouldn't be having this
conversation in the first place so
speculate in your informed way about
their motive like what do they know that
they don't want us to know do you think
well i if i could be completely
forthcoming i think they don't know a
lot and that in itself is is is probably
what they don't want to necessarily have
a conversation about um even recently
when you when you listen to the pentagon
spokesperson no offense but there's no
there's no indication that they're going
to be open and forthcoming with the
american people when you look at the
legislation that has been presented in
this ndaa national defense authorization
act this is historic i mean this
basically tells the us government both
the director of national intelligence
and the secretary of defense you will
report to congress both at the
classified and the unclassified
versions and oh by the way you're going
to create a a field team you're going to
create a capability to go out and not
just sit back and relax and wait for
information to come to you but you now
have to be proactive you have to go out
and actually collect that information as
it's happening and then you have to
report it to us and last but not least
if there's information that you can't
report because it's too classified you
have to report that fact to congress too
so this is this is really a fantastic i
think i mean it's huge it's it's very
comprehensive it's pages and pages and i
got to tell you i'm really really proud
of congress for it really quick i just
want to ask you a bottom line question
do you know anybody who's deeply
knowledgeable on this subject who
studies at the pentagon for example who
believes that these objects are from
russia
and china who believes they're
terrestrial they're foreign military
aircraft
there's a couple individuals i'm not
going to call them out uh that for
whatever reason still remain
extremely apprehensive about this topic
but at the end of the day you know what
i say fine let the data speak for itself
let's now that we've got a mechanism to
actually collect and analyze this
information
let the data speak for itself and then
and then they'll come to the natural
conclusion of what this is
yeah it's pretty clearly not from russia
or china i would say just my view pretty
clueless ondo appreciate your coming on
thank you